- [Mark] All right, Margaret.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Margaret, where'd you grow up?
Where you from, originally?
- El Centro, California.
- [Mark] El Centro, where's El Centro?
- [Margaret] It's by
Indio, in Palm Springs.
- [Mark] And tell me about
your childhood? You had both?
With your parents?
- I lived with my mom and dad
till I was four years old.
And then from four on up
well, I was still at my mom's house when
I was four years old and I
saw my dad shoot and kill her.
And,
from four
to 13,
(Margaret sobs)
from 4 to 13 I kept getting raped
by my uncles, my older
cousins, and my dad.
I kept getting beat by my
grandmother by extension cords.
And then, I got pregnant at 13
and had a home abortion.
At 14 I was trying to commit suicide
and they sent me to a state hospital
and I tried to kill myself in there
and tried to kill and
hurt other staff members.
When I was 15, I had got
out of the state hospital.
I got out and got raped by police,
and my brother ended up killin 'em.
- [Mark] Your brother killed a cop?
- Killed the cop in San Bernardino.
Because I got raped by 'em.
And then I got pregnant again
and I had my own not a home abortion,
but just a regular abortion.
At 17, I had my own apartment
and I was with an older guy,
like I was 17 he was like 39.
And I was always having older guys
because I looked up to 'em
and I respected 'em.
I started having sex
when I was nine years old
because I just felt that
that was the thing to do.
And then I was sexual active from nine til
18 I was having sex like constantly,
like every day, like at least
30 days, 30 times a day.
When I was 19, I got into porn
till I was 25, I did porn.
That's it.
- [Mark] That's a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So when your parents,
your dad went to prison, I assume?
- Yeah he went to prison for four years.
He claim something insane.
Criminally insane or something.
- [Mark] So he only did four years?
And who raised you?
- My grandmother.
- [Mark] After that you
were with your grandmother?
- My grandmother and my grandfather,
and my grandma kept beating on me
and she was letting my
uncle and them rape me.
- [Mark] Wow, what a childhood?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How do you, I mean,
all of this must've
affected you as an adult,
so it's,
- Yes
I have PTSD, severe PTSD,
I have flashbacks, and
nightmares about it every day.
- [Mark] Do you have kids now?
- Have four.
- [Mark] And, did you raise them?
- I raised them til they was old enough
then I put them up for open adoption
because I didn't want them going through
abuse relationships like I did.
I didn't want them to see me getting beat.
So I gave them up for adoption.
- [Mark] And now you're living homeless
here in Skid Row?
- Yes, I'm on Skid Row here.
Been here for three years.
- [Mark] Living in a tent?
- Living tent to tent.
- [Mark] And how is that going for you?
- Not good, cause I'm
selling my body or whatever.
I'm not having fun.
- [Mark] You're still doing it?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I mean, it seems like
that's all you've known since
you were a child, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You can't really.
- But I'm getting paid this time
but when I was growing up I wasn't.
- [Mark] Yeah.
But working on Skid Row
you can't be making a lot?
- I don't do it on Skid Row.
I go to Hollywood.
- [Mark] Oh, you go to Hollywood.
- Yup
- [Mark] And do you work on your own
or with a pimp?
- I work on my own.
I'm independent.
- [Mark] Is that, is that tricky?
- By myself, yes.
- [Mark] Is that tough though?
Do guys?
- Yeah, it's kinda tough,
cause you're you need
someone to protect you
and you don't have that.
So.
- [Mark] Cause if you, if
you don't get protection,
then what happens?
- Anything can happen to you.
So you got to protect
yourself you gotta learn
how to put your guard up.
- [Mark] And then what happens with the,
with your, the guys who pick you up?
You have troubles sometimes there too?
- Yeah I do.
Then I put 'em in check
and then that's it.
Then they have to follow all the rules.
- [Mark] How do you put 'em in check?
- I tell 'em what it's going to be
and if they don't do it,
do what I tell them to do then it's over.
And I say, if you don't want that
then they'll start acting right.
- [Mark] Yeah, and drugs
are part of your life?
- Uh yeah.
- [Mark] When did it?
- Just crack.
- [Mark] When did it start for you?
- 2013
- [Mark] So you went through all this
stuff as a child, and didn't
really take the drugs until?
- Yeah, 2013.
- [Mark] Wow.
- On my birthday, my
husband or my second husband
gave me an eight ball
I just smoked by myself
and I never knew what it was
and I smoked and I liked it.
So, I just started doing
it and kept doing it.
- [Mark] What's the
hardest part of your life?
You've been through so much.
What's the hardest part for you?
- Seeing my mom get killed.
- [Mark] Yeah. I'm sure.
Did you see it happen?
- Yeah, I was sitting on my mom's lap
when my dad shot and
killed her in the head.
Shot and killed her.
I was sitting on my mom's
lap when she just died
in my lap, my arm.
- [Mark] Wow.
In you're twenties and
you were having kids
and stuff like that, what were you doing?
How were you supporting yourself?
- Porn.
Doing Porn.
- [Mark] You were doing porn?
- Was doing porn and
then, I started stripping.
- [Mark] I'm sure there's a connection
between the sexual abuse
you had as a kid and you're
working porn,
- Yeah.
- [Instructor] And what
you're doing today, right?
- Yes.
- [Mark] What emotion do
you deal with the most?
You must have a lot.
- Depression.
- [Both] Depression.
- [Mark] Have you, tried therapy
or anything like that?
- I tried, but I couldn't
talk about my problems.
It was hard to talk about her problems.
Huh?
I tried to do therapy,
but it was hard to talk about problems.
I wouldn't talk about 'em.
- [Mark] You're doing a good job here.
- I just kept them in.
- [Mark] How do you view life?
I mean, do you see life as just a
everyone's out for themselves
and everyone's just trying to
take advantage of each other?
- No, actually I was
planning on killing myself
on Christmas overdosing.
- [Mark] Coming up?
- Because I can't take life no more.
- [Mark] Have you tried suicide before?
- Yes.
I died nine times in
2007 when I overdosed.
I died nine times and I
thought that's the way to go.
- [Mark] Overdose with what?
- On different pills,
- [Mark] Pills.
- Cause they got me on a
lot of pills right now.
Back then I'd take $900,
900 pills, and they gave
me more pills now, so.
- [Mark] And how are your kids doing?
- Good, I guess.
I don't talk to them.
I'm like embarrassed to talk to 'em,
because what I'm going through.
They might ask me, what
am I doing or whatever.
I don't want to lie to 'em.
I don't talk to 'em.
- [Mark] Wow, what
would help you the most,
you think to not be suicidal,
to not be so self destructive?
- To have a good guy in my life
and someone that understands
me, and respects me.
- [Mark] Have you ever had
a good guy in your life?
- Nope.
All of them was abusive.
- [Mark] What kind of abuse
have your relationships
have your relationships brought you?
- [Margaret] Well one last, two years ago,
he gave me a black eye and
broke three bones in my eye.
And, he put me in jail
by lying and saying that I threatened him
but I wasn't even in the area at the time.
And so now I got parole for
three years, no probation,
I'm sorry, probation for three years,
and I keep going in and out
of jail because of him lying.
And I have a warrant now because he lied.
There's nothing I can do about it.
- [Mark] So you should actually
be back in jail right now?
- [Margaret] I'm supposed to be in jail,
but they're not taking me because
they know the Covid thing.
And they know that he was lying so.
- [Mark] What helps you survive?
You've been through so much.
- [Margaret] Ho'ing.
(Mark stutters)
- [Mark] How old are you?
- [Margaret] 41.
- [Mark] 41?
- [Margaret] I just turned 41, Sunday.
(Mark sighs)
- [Mark] Do you see that so much of,
all of this really is not,
none of it's your fault,
you just were born into a family
that brought you lots of
headaches and craziness?
- Yeah.
I realize that sometimes.
It's kinda hard to believe it sometimes.
- [Mark] Do you have siblings?
- I have one brother.
He's in and out of prison for murder.
I don't talk to him no more.
- [Mark] Have you ever done
anything else for work?
Other than sex work?
- Porn, stripping, I was
a manager at a daycare,
a child's daycare whatever,
and...
I used to, work at,
what's it called on
some kind of pet thing.
I think it's pet a lion
or something lion's
in Omaha, Nebraska.
I used to work with
them for like two years.
- [Mark] Were you happier when
you were doing a square job?
- No.
- [Mark] What was it was?
- [Margaret] It was boring to me.
- [Mark] It was boring?
Do you find the work that you're doing now
satisfying or fulfilling in any way?
- Yes.
- [Mark] You do?
- [Margaret] Yeah.
- [Mark] What about what works for you?
- [Margaret] It takes my edge off,
and makes me feel good.
- [Mark] So it, it boosts
your self esteem a little bit.
- [Margaret] A little bit, yeah.
- [Mark] You have regulars
to take care of you?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- When I was 19, when
I started doing porn.
- [Mark] And looking back at your life,
is there anything that,
I mean, do you have regrets
or do you just see it
as you're just surviving?
- I just regret being born,
- [Mark] You do regret that?
- Because my dad used to always tell me
I was a big ole fuck up I
should never have been born
and he only made boys and all that, so.
That's why I shouldn't be born.
I shouldn't be a girl.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- How to respect myself more
and how to be a strong person.
- [Mark] Yeah, you're strong.
Do you feel like you love
and respect yourself?
- Somewhat.
- [Mark] You're getting better?
- I'm getting better but
I'm getting I'm stronger.
- [Mark] What's the worst
thing that's happened to you?
Working the streets like this?
- Slicing people's throat,
because they want to be aggressive.
- [Mark] You get some
crazy Johns sometimes?
- Yeah they try to be aggressive,
and I gotta prove to them
that it's not going down
or I slice their throat so they can learn.
They can remember not to
do that to nobody else.
- [Mark] You get asked to do things
you're not comfortable doing?
- All the time.
- [Mark] Yeah.
How do you get out of that?
- Just say, I don't feel good
or just say I'm gonna leave
or something like that
and then they change their mind.
- [Mark] Do you carry
anything to protect yourself?
- Yes, knives.
- [Mark] Knives?
You've had to use them?
- Yes I have.
On 10 different guys.
I sliced all their throats,
and I had to stab one of them.
- [Mark] Do you have contact
with your family, your kids?
- I try not to cause I'm embarrassed
of the way I'm living right now.
- [Mark] Yeah, shame is a
big part of it all. Isn't it?
- Yeah, and I don't want them to know
anything about it.
That's why I wanted to die on Christmas.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- That's why I wanted to die on Christmas.
- [Mark] I mean how would you die?
- I wanted to kill myself, overdosing.
- [Mark] You want to, OD on Christmas?
Which is the day after tomorrow?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Or the day after?
- At midnight.
Midnight tomorrow night.
I was supposed to overdose.
- [Mark] That's your plan?
- Yes.
- [Mark] I think I'm going to get in the,
in the way of your plan.
( Mark chuckles)
I'm going to try.
I can't let you do that.
I cannot let you do that.
And you're staying with your sister?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Who I know?
- Green Eyes.
My sister's.
My sister's name is Green Eyes.
- [Mark] Your older sister?
- My older like 10 years older than me.
- [Mark] Is it nice
staying with your sister?
- Sometimes if she don't get drunk
and then she start acting
crazy, then I have to act crazy.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- But she don't want to fight me
cause she know I will tear her up.
(both chuckle)
- [Mark] So depression is a thing for you?
- Depression.
- [Mark] Has to be right?
- Yeah and not sleeping, insomnia.
- [Mark] Oh, you don't sleep?
- I don't sleep until I do crystal.
I don't sleep for like three or four days.
And then I sleep probably
like four hours in a month.
- [Mark] The reason
you're considering suicide
is just because why?
- Because I'm sick of life.
Sick of the way I'm living.
I need a better way to live.
- [Mark] What would help you?
- A good man that respects me,
and understands me and me
just being off the streets.
- [Mark] What are you doing for Christmas?
- Nothing not that I know of.
- [Mark] I'm going to
kidnap you for Christmas.
(Margaret chuckles)
- Okay.
- [Mark] Make sure you
don't commit suicide.
I can't, I can't let you do that.
Will you hang out with me for Christmas?
- Yes I will.
- [Mark] Very good, it's a date.
- Okay.
(both chuckle)
- [Mark] Have you considered
suicide before in your life?
- Yes, in 2007, I was
raped and I killed myself,
liked I overdosed on 900
pills I died nine times
and then come to find out I was pregnant.
After they put me in an induced coma.
After I killed like died.
They put me in an induced coma so
I come to find out I was pregnant.
- [Mark] And did you keep that baby?
- Yes, cause he didn't do nothing wrong
and he deserved to live
like everybody else
like everybody else and
he did nothing wrong
so I wasn't gonna take it out on him.
He's like a special baby to me.
- [Mark] And who's raising him?
- I put them up for
adoption, open adoption.
He's with a family in Omaha, Nebraska.
- [Mark] Do you talk to him at all?
- Last time I talked to was two years ago,
when I wasn't on drugs.
I mean not doing drugs like I do now.
- [Mark] Is right now the
highest point of your drug use?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Because I'm out here on the streets?
- [Mark] Yeah, it's a rough life here.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's cold.
- [Mark] What's the hardest
part of your life now?
Just the.
- The depression and.
- [Mark] Everything, being
apart from your kids.
- Yes, missing my kids.
- [Mark] You've had a
horrible life it sounds.
- And now PTSD, yeah.
I have flashbacks and
nightmares every night
and everyday I have flashbacks.
- [Mark] Yeah the PTSD must be.
- Severe PTSD.
- [Mark] Have you ever been in love?
- Huh?
- No.
I've tried to love people,
but they'd always hurt me, so.
They always want to beat on me or whatever
say they love me, but it
never I never could find it.
- [Mark] You won't be able to
handle hanging out with me.
- Why?
(Margaret giggles)
- [Mark] Because I'll be nice to you.
I don't think you'll
know what to do with it.
I've never hit anybody in my life.
- Oh, that's good to know.
- [Mark] And I'm definitely
not gonna let you take pills.
You want to take pills?
Is that how you would do it?
- Yes.
- [Mark] I'm not going to let
you do that.
- I would overdose.
- [Mark] You take pills as well?
Is that a?
- Yes I do.
- [Mark] It's one of your things?
- For diabetes, seizures, asthma,
and low thyroid,
high cholesterol.
(Mark chuckles)
Heart problems.
- [Mark] I'm going to have my hands full
here for Christmas.
- Everything.
No.
- [Mark] Well Margaret,
I'm concerned for you,
but I'm excited that you're gonna let me
kidnap you from Skid Row,
- Okay.
- [Mark] for a little bit.
Maybe I can talk some sense into you.
- Hope so.
- [Mark] All right.
Well, we'll figure out
how and why and when
and all that and.
- Okay.
- [Mark] And maybe we'll
do an update one day
and see how you are in
three or four months
or something like that.
- [Margaret] All right.
- [Mark] Cause I'm hoping
you're going to turn the corner
on all this depression.
- [Margaret] Hope so too.
- [Mark] Cause you deserve a better life.
Everybody deserves a great life
and you especially with all
the tough breaks you've had.
- Okay, thank you.
- [Mark] All right.
- All right.
- [Mark] Well we'll, two days?
Tomorrow's Christmas Eve right?
- Yes
- [Mark] All right, we're
gonna figure this out.
- Okay.
- [Mark] All right give me a hug.
I'm not gonna let you take pills
and kill yourself.
- [Margaret] Okay.
- [Mark] You definitely can't do that.